that does help when i'm helping others
so
as i've moved and moved around and lived
in different places i've also
been on the job search many times on my
own and made different transitions
so i want you to think about a road trip
imagine you're going 3 000 miles i know
a lot of us feel cooped up at home and
haven't had a chance to do that as much
as we want to lately
but think about that road trip and what
do you need before you go on the road
trip tell me in the chat like what's the
first thing you're gonna make sure you
have
give me some of your thoughts
any thoughts on the road trip what's the
first thing you want
i know for me
i'm gonna share my thought is i want to
make sure
back in the old days aging myself i
always wanted a map
but now most of us all want to make sure
that we have our destination and our gps
and when we think about that anytime we
make a big change we take a big trip
it's all about like we want to make sure
we know that destination now we might
have
pit stops and we might take some u-turns
and
curve around a little bit and that road
could be whiny windy
and but we we ultimately always have
that destination in mind and we have
that gps that tells us how we're going
to get there
life isn't always so easy that gps
doesn't always
give us that exact path but when we're
looking for a job starting with the
destination and really having that end
in mind
is really important and i work with a
lot of people who i find
sometimes have like this big wide open
book and they start taking udacity
courses and wanting to get into maybe a
certain area of tech
and really haven't started to think
about what what the destination is what
job they're really aiming for
and again it can change it can evolve
but having a target having a goal can
really help
you set yourself up for success
and i like this quote to help think
about it from stephen covey if
many of you probably read the seven
habits of highly effective people
but to begin with the end in mind means
to start with a clear
understanding of your destination and
remember that's an understanding of your
destination that means
again it's flexible it means that
to know where you're going so that you
better understand where you are now
and then you take the steps in that
you're always taking steps in the right
direction to get to that
end goal and thinking about that as you
embark on the job search as you're
thinking about the job search
you know and we're going to talk a lot
about these target jobs but
you know put it up on your bullet point
board write it down
have it on your computer remind yourself
like this is what i'm aiming for
so that the days when you're maybe going
through some of these programming
classes
you're sitting listening webinars you're
out trying to network
think always about what that end is in
mind what is it that you're really
aiming for
so today we are going to talk a lot
about keeping that beginning with the
end in mind
we're going to help you with some tips
to get off to an efficient job search
we're going to look at your app
application materials checklist making
sure you
you know what you need and some
resources to help help you get
all of those things in order and we're
going gonna have plenty of time for
questions
so again here we go again begin with the
end in mind know the job you're
targeting that is the destination
and a lot of people say well i don't do
i have to have the ultimate dream job
you know how much are you telling me i
have to have here right remember this
can be a stepping stone it doesn't mean
it's the ultimate dream job where you
see yourself
you know finishing off your career
someday in the long future
it could be the next stop but the the
point is that you
know what you're trying to get right now
and if you have a goal of where you want
to be in five 10 years 15 years that's
awesome but don't feel like you have to
have that
just to get started on this next roll
because it can be flexible
and targets can move and we're going to
talk a lot about
having a starting at your job search
sometimes with a really small focus
think about that
bullseye in the middle of that um
dartboard
and if you start your job search in this
really small target
and you say this is this is my five
dream companies this is what i really
want
that's awesome and fantastic to focus
your
efforts there then gradually as maybe
you exhaust that resource
or you put out all your feelers you put
out as many applications as you can in
that small focus
then you can start to let the search
field grow a little and maybe look at
some second choice companies or some
related companies or maybe some new
companies that you've thought of or came
across that
sound interesting to you
so when you begin with the end in mind
first thing i recommend is
research job descriptions i talk to so
many people who
think they have an idea of what they
want to do they start taking classes
they're aiming for something
but they haven't really looked at the
meat of the job descriptions yet
if you know you want to be a product
manager start with
you know big companies typically have
very
elaborate job descriptions so sometimes
those are the best to look at to get an
idea of
what all it could encompass now
i will warn you they also like to put a
lot of information in their job
descriptions that sometimes it's
overkill
in terms of what you might be looking
for so as you research the job
the job descriptions start getting a
feel for what's out there if i'm
looking for a product manager role i'm
going to look maybe what does a google
product manager look like what is a
startup product manager over here
maybe a consumer good product and then
i'm going to start to feel like i have
some of these ideal next jobs i can
start seeing
where i know that i fit in i'm going to
look at
where i know my strengths are maybe it's
new skills i've built
or something i've done in the past that
aligns really well with that job
then i'm also going to look at maybe
where i have gaps and we don't want to
ignore that right
if we're looking down the job
description and feeling really good and
go wow just ignore those couple points
that they're asking for
you don't want to do that you want to
make sure you're really looking
where am i aligned and where do i have
gaps and
obviously those areas where you're
aligned and you have those strengths
pointing those out in your resume
putting that in your linkedin making
sure that's visible
where you have gaps that's where you
want to either
maybe some quick things that you can
upskill a project you can do
something you need to practice maybe
it's something in a new programming
language that you need to get a little
more practice with to feel a little more
confident
then you start to look at those ideal
jobs
then we're going to start and then in
step three there we're going to talk
about prioritizing and analyzing the key
job factors and those are the keys to
you it's not the same for everyone
there's times in our life where maybe
the factor that's most important
is location maybe it's work-life balance
maybe it's money it can be very
different for different people
at different times in our lives
different stages of our lives
so as you start researching job
descriptions look i want you to
really look beyond the title you might
start with title so if you know you want
to be a you want to be in
a data analyst so that's obviously going
to be where you start
but if you're not feeling like you're
really getting
the exact job that you want maybe you
start
thinking about going beyond the title
even even
adjusting the title slightly junior data
analyst senior data analyst
associate data analyst and then
expand a little bit on the titles see
what's out there then start looking at
different searches and different
keywords so i might
say okay now i'm really good in sql i
know that i love working with different
databases i'm going to just type
put those keywords in in different areas
maybe on linkedin
maybe i'm going to look at indeed so
that i'm getting different job titles
coming up and i can start expanding
this target area that i'm looking at
the next thing is the quick scan and i
can't emphasize this enough i find
that a lot of people will look at a job
description
and they will think about it and they
will debate it and they will wonder if
they're a good fit
for days or weeks before they apply
so in terms of leading an efficient job
search there's
a couple little tricks that i want to
share that can help you
with that quick scan
i want you to ask yourself you're going
to read that job description
really quickly and after that quick scan
ask yourself
am i confident i can do the job big
picture do i feel
like i can do that job next do i meet
about 75 of the requirements remember
when i said that
companies like to put a lot of uh con
content in those descriptions most
jobs they would not expect you to be
able to do 100 of what they're asking
for
and i'll get back to that later third
question is do i think i would like the
job
and if you answer yes pretty quickly to
all three of these
i want you to either if you don't have
time to apply that minute
if you're in let's say linkedin or
indeed you can save that
put a heart on it like it whatever you
need to do in that platform
and save it to apply for later that goes
in the yes pile
if if obviously if you if you say no to
most
of those you're going to kick it out and
delete it you're going to ignore it
if you're not quite sure and it's a
maybe then maybe you want to read it a
little bit closer
see how you're feeling if you're not
sure maybe put it in
put it back in that yes pile for a while
and come back to it later
so the point is just as quick as
recruiters are going to be filtering
through resumes that's how quick i want
you filtering through job descriptions
i want you to look i want you to ask
yourself those three questions make a
really quick decision
if you have time apply right then
don't over analyze do i think they'll
like me do i
don't try to predict and project what
they're thinking on their end think
about what you believe and what you know
what you want because that's all you're
in control of
so by taking the approach of it's up to
you to decide am i confident i can do
the job do i meet 75
of the requirements and do i think i
would like it then apply
you can you know if you get the call
back if you
if they send you an email you can go way
deeper and you will go way deeper in
that job description before ever getting
into the interview process and probably
as you're applying and maybe preparing a
cover letter
maybe tweaking your resume if you need
to a little bit for that application
you might then be going a little deeper
anyway but don't let
maybe one bullet point scare you away
from applying or
make you think about and analyze that
for
for weeks on end and and lose the
opportunity or just
be really inefficient with your time
and that that 75 of the requirements
again
there's a few reasons why there's a lot
of content in job descriptions one is
because
the physician could grow and they they
don't want to they want to hedge their
bets and they want to make sure
someone's saying
you know i'm willing to take on more
work i'm willing and
able to get into this space
even if some of that's growing into the
space
also at times they have three or four
managers who are maybe hiring a data
analyst and
you know i'm saying i want this garfield
singing wants that
uh leonardo singing wants that so i take
all of that as the hr manager and i put
it all in there so that i'm covered
right because i'm not gonna put in six
different job descriptions
so quick scan make the decision apply
for the job
let them decide later if
if they think you're a good match right
you don't need to stress about what
what they might be thinking about you
and let me just i'm going to stop
sharing here for a second and just see
if there are any questions
it looks like a couple of popped up and
in my
my chat for some reason is not wanting
to pop
out for me so i'm going to
just look here and see what questions
have come up
what about the cases where i don't know
if i would like the job because it's a
new area
even if i had the theoretical or
academic experience we know that in
practice it could be different
leonardo that's a good question and i
think that you know in those cases if
you're not
sure you're really going to like it but
you you know you're qualified you know
you'd be a good fit
probably go ahead and apply you can look
deeper later
now if you've applied and
you start doing a little more research
you get called for an interview
and you're really not sure like if
you've deci if you've decided i don't
want that job then you don't want to
waste their time either and you might
politely decline and say that you know
that
you don't want to waste their time with
the interview you've moved on to
something else
if you're still not sure it's okay to
have that first interview and have some
conversations and learn more about the
job
the interview process really should be a
two-way street
it should be just as much as you want to
know about that company
they want to know about you right so i
think we all go into interviews thinking
oh it's all about
them assessing me but you should be
assessing the company
so much at the same time and that's
where when we really kind of
flip that thinking and and going into
interviews
we come up with better questions in the
end we have better conversations
as opposed to feeling like i'm up you
know on the stand of the courtroom being
drilled that's not the way it should be
should really be a conversation where
you're learning more
let's see the next question
how do you find a job when your nano
degree is not a recognized standard and
you don't have
any recognized certifications so
what i have found with the nano degrees
is
first in tech in general a lot of people
know about udacity
and the more people that are taking
classes are alumni base is growing it's
getting stronger and stronger
but what really sets you apart is not so
much that certificate
but it's your projects it's the projects
you've completed
and that's really where udacity makes a
big difference is the quality
of the projects the robust and complex
nature of the product
projects so it's important to show those
projects on your resume
to show them on linkedin so that then
when you get to the interview
you can talk through those projects and
give them the confidence
that you have that that they you want
them to have
in you
and thank you earlier for the
the messages on what you wanted on your
road trip we've got gas planning
milestone food and a map i love it so
thank you
uh let's see what else we've got here
another question
i think i just covered that one and
another one popped up
what's the best way to say no if we
don't know the answer to an interview
question
that is a good point i think the i'm
going to give you a couple strategies on
this and it could be a whole session on
talking about interviewing
but first before you go into any
interview i want you to think of your
top
five to 10 stories that you have
they could be stories describing
projects you've done they could be
stories describing a team you've worked
on
a challenge you've had stories that can
really show
a bigger picture of you can show
how you're how you have performed in the
workplace how you've
managed a team how you have completed a
big project
and when you have those stories ready
before you go into an interview
it's a lot easier to be able to field
all kinds of different questions
now if they say to you you know angela
can you
program in python and i've never written
code in my life i i have to say no right
there's nothing around that
like clearly i shouldn't be in the
interview if that question is that far
out of left field so hopefully you're
the the questions they're asking you
aren't you should be
already in the interview a pretty decent
match for what they're looking for
so if it's something you're not as
familiar with
or if it's something new you've been
working on it's okay to say you know
that is an area where i've been
you know skilling up i've i've completed
some projects i've taken a course or
you know maybe because i've done a lot
in r
i know that uh python and this is where
you
all you uh python experts can laugh at
me and my knowledge starts to get a
little rusty
but maybe i could say that something
i've done that's similar that i've
and i've started to look at that code
and i'm getting more familiar and i feel
comfortable
learning it and picking it up a little
quicker so anything that you can say
that
kind of has a a little bit of a parallel
that you can describe is a good way to
to bring up a different story
and show your other strengths
let's see
i'm going through a couple more
questions
how much detail on the projects this is
a good question how much detail on the
project
should you include on your resume and
job profile
so if if you are
let's say you're a very experienced data
analyst and you've got a lot of data
analytics work experience and then
you've taken
the data science nanodegree to upskill
in different areas
then your project section probably
doesn't need to be
as elaborate because you have all that
work experience behind
you so your project section is
complementary just adds a little bit
more
now if you have taken the data science
nanodegree but you
have never worked in data it's all new
to you
those projects are super super super
important so if i've only ever worked
let's say as a financial analyst
and now i've picked up these data
courses i want that project section to
be a little bit bigger a little bit
stronger maybe even a little more
prominent
i'm gonna put it at the top of my resume
as opposed to maybe under my work
experience
so it's really when you think like what
what's the gap
what's the reason for your projects is
it to show like this is all i've done in
the space and i need you to see it
or i've been doing a little bit of all
of this and the project is like a bonus
on mine
then that can help you gauge how much
you should have it
now it should not be in any case it
should not be super technical
it needs to just you know i i recommend
naming the project so let's say you've
done the bike sharing app
project and so you're going to name that
bike sharing app project
then oftentimes you'll put udacity maybe
in parentheses or underneath it
and give one sentence to describe that
project
so you might say you know and always say
the like the what you learned or the
outcome of it and the technology you
used
having that technology and there's
really important if it was something you
did in c
plus c plus needs to be in there because
that's what
it gives you that keyword on your resume
and it also describes the technical
nature of what you did
let's see how do you know it's the right
time to start applying if you already
have a job
maybe you've developed an interest in a
field and start learning about it but
don't know when to start applying as
well
you know i think the first thing i would
do before jumping into a new space
is think about networking in that space
talking to other people who work
in the area where you really like to be
and
by doing that you'll start to get a
better sense of if you're ready is it a
good time to switch
and instead of maybe taking the first
step as being actively applying
the first step is actively networking
actively connecting
and and get a sense if you're ready for
that
i will come back i see more questions
this is awesome i love that there's so
many of you
popping questions in there i am going to
pop back to the slides for a little bit
and then we will come back
to your questions
so thinking about the different factors
in the job so let's say now you're at
the point you've done the quick scan
you've you've decided to apply and maybe
you're
something to kind of do it in tandem
so you're thinking about like what is
that dream job what it what am i really
targeting what's
important to me what is ideal
and then what's acceptable right because
we all have like
the ideal compensation that we want but
then we also have kind of like this
acceptable range as well
so these are some of the areas that you
want to think about what's most
important to you
what's ideal what's acceptable it's also
good i often recommend
giving yourself a like a ranking scale
maybe you put these in the order that's
most important to you
maybe you give it a a one to five rating
and and really
analyze this to think is it most
important
some people and title is really
important they're really trying to move
up in their organization or over to
another organization and
title is going to have a high priority
some people moving into a new space they
really don't care about the title as
long as the function of the job is right
so think about what's most important to
you is it the skills that this is the
skills you can build and grow in
is it the industry you're in is that the
type of organization do you want to be
in a large more established organization
do you want to be in a startup do you
want to be in
an organization is the culture important
to you
and and obviously all of these things to
some extent are important to all of us
but it's important going into as you
target jobs
as you start interviewing really knowing
your priority
priorities so that you feel
more confident in as you do those quick
scans
what it is you're looking for what what
it is that and obviously you're not
going to maybe know all of these
exact factors and all the details before
interviewing but it can at least get you
thinking
this way and you have in your mind this
is what's most important to me
so a few things to think about in the in
this different
uh these different categories the first
is
your title right some people you is it
too senior is it is it
are you worried you won't be able to do
the job is it too junior and you feel
like it's a step down
or is it a lateral move and that's not
really what you're looking for
um function is it exactly what you've
done is it similar is it too advanced
similar to title skills are the skills
that they like and want you to use
what you've been building what you've
been growing and what you want to do
is the industry is it something i like
something i know something i believe in
uh the organization and when i think
when i say something i believe in
i worked with someone recently who was
working in an industry that
she really had struggled with the values
of the industry and so she
she did struggle staying there and was
really looking to get out and said she
probably
all along should have maybe not been in
that industry
again organization is it a startup is it
a large corporate
is it a big tech company do they give a
good
work-life balance what's the culture
the location obviously we all know
remotes happening a lot these days
is your location the most important that
helps you narrow down that search pretty
quick
right some people say oh it's just tough
because i i can
only work in in nashville or you know
in in paris wherever you are that's
actually
sometimes you know when people say i can
go anywhere i'll you know
live work anywhere i'll do whatever
sometimes that's a lot harder to
get your hands on the search and grasp
it because
the playing field's so big so even if
you are thinking of
a country that or a you know several
cities
try to try to narrow it as much as you
feel comfortable at first
so that you can get some momentum in
your search and and have
strategies and goals for kind of digging
into those spaces
compensation you may not know exactly
but you can research
glassdoor is a great place talking to
people in the industry
and kind of estimating that potential
but really knowing
knowing personally what where you want
to be compensated what you think is fair
what you think it would be an awesome
maybe stretch compensation
and really that that space where you're
most comfortable
so as you look through these jobs and
you you're you're looking at that
end destination right you might find the
exact job description that's exactly
what you want
you might find about five or six job
descriptions that you like pieces of all
of them
sit down and create that ideal next job
put it in writing
see what it looks like help yourself
really visualize where you're headed
and you know if we had a magic wand and
you end up finding that exact job then
let's all celebrate chances are it's not
going to be exactly what you create
but it really does help you you've
prioritized
you know what you want to do you've set
this goal and it makes it way
easier searching for a job when you've
got
maybe two or three job titles a certain
industry or two that you're looking at
you can really go deeper and start
networking and
digging into those companies and making
connections and making interviews happen
rather than having this wide open book
again that ideal next job is going to
give you set your vision it's going to
help you focus and it's going to help
you have a targeted search
and you're going to feel a lot more
efficient like you're making progress
and getting momentum which is really
important as we all know when you
when you're out of work and you start
feeling that stress
and you don't feel progress and you
don't feel momentum
by not having these having the vision
having the focus
having the end goal it makes it really
hard to have an effective search
but remember targets can change allow
yourself to be flexible
it's i know and in one hand i'm saying
like have this tight focus and stay here
and
but that's to help you get started it
can grow
it can change it can evolve and that's
okay
so how do you get there how do you get
to that next job and how do you make
sure that
you've got everything in place to to get
those interviews
when you navigate the job search you
want to make sure your application
materials are ready that's one of the
first thing obviously your resume your
linkedin
we're going to talk about how udacity
can help you with that and really making
sure you're setting daily goals
every day if if you're maybe maybe some
of you are
still working maybe some of you are
working on udacity
and not working full-time right now but
set those goals how much time can you
commit each day
and and have it not just be
the search shouldn't be just applying
for jobs it should
include networking include a little
research include
every every time you know every third
job you apply for even
look at your resume again well look at
it every time before you attach it and
send it
but spend it you know every few jobs sit
down and really think about it because
there's something i can do to make it
even better
udacity resources will talk about
um again as i mentioned with the
application materials
we have reviews of your linkedin your
resume
and cover letter for all udacity
students that's all included in your
nano degree
your resume doesn't have to be perfect
for you to go through that it's not
meant to be
so do the project you get lots of tips
and advice
you'll make some edits and then you
submit it for feedback
it's not going to anyone else don't
worry it's not getting posted anywhere
it's just for that reviewer to help
give you feedback you can also get
additional support in your one-to-one
coaching sessions on all of those
separately we also have a github review
that's relevant
only to certain nano degrees obviously
not every person has a github
so if that's relevant to you can also
get that reviewed i will say that
the career coaches are not usually the
person to ask about github
that needs to be one of our technical
reviewers for that
some of you might need a portfolio so if
you are a content creator if you are
doing ux design those often require
portfolio
that is something that we can give you
resources to help make sure you're
getting that right
you can talk about those in one-to-one
coaching depending on how technical
it um we can share what we've seen from
other people
i know i've seen several portfolios in
different areas and and i can help
give guidance on this is what else i've
seen maybe this could make it better
and that's how you and and peer feedback
is a great
thing with portfolios asking a friend or
ex colleague
classmate that you might have had in the
past to look at your portfolio
so what can be some of your next steps i
recommend
com that should not say compete your
udacity career project so say complete
and so make sure you're doing those
career projects book a one-to-one
coaching session
some people like to do the projects and
then go into
their coaching sessions some people vice
versa whatever you do
don't wait till the end of your
nanodegree to get started if you know
your
goal is to get a job get started with
your coaching services
with the career projects as soon as
possible
uh work on one at a time have a meeting
with a coach
and get through some of this so that
when you're done with the nano degree or
if you have a time
or if you're if you're waiting for maybe
a certain
time to start looking for a job based on
something in your personal life or a
move or
your old job then you want to start
getting everything in place so that you
get that momentum going
that is the end of the content that i
have i see a lot of questions up so i'm
going to stop
sharing so i can make my screen bigger
and get to
the questions also if you
have a question you would like to unmute
and ask
you can also type in and let me know
that we do have a big group so i'd
rather
it'll be better if everyone stays muted
because
we'll get a lot of background noise if
we undo everybody if you want to ask a
question go ahead and type it in
do we have a limit on the number of
coaching sessions
yes there is a limit they're all a
little bit different but generally
speaking you get about
one per month that you're enrolled and
then you have
up to a year to use those
and i will say that you know some of you
that have booked you know that there can
be a bit of a wait
to get availability in a coach's
calendar so again it's
another reason to make sure you're
booking well in advance
uh let's see more questions what things
should we avoid while writing a cover
letter the biggest thing to
two things i'd say to avoid when writing
a cover letter is one
to make it way too generic saying i have
good leadership skills strong
communication right like
you need to give them give them a story
give them some information
and don't just regurgitate your resume
it's not about saying i went to school
here and i worked here and i did this
give them one or two stories think about
what couple things do you want them to
know that's not so obvious in your
resume
or maybe it's a point that's obvious but
you can give a little more detail
give a little more of a story there
let's see uh someone asked if they get
if you're in
more than one nanodegree do i get more
than one session per month i don't think
so i think they've just
recently clarified with us
that it would be one per month
regardless of how many nano degrees
you're in but i
could it's a little confusing and i
would recommend and i'll type in the
chat here
the career support email that
you can send they can let you know
specifically to you
how many coaching sessions you have and
when you get them someone asked how many
pages should a resume be for refreshers
i s
one page for sure if you are less than
10 years of work experience
one page is where you should be in
europe
and asia that can be a little bit
different sometimes they like a little
more detail and you could probably go to
two pages
the big tech companies will all are
typically
require one page only at any level
so i recommend in in any case have a
one-page resume have
get it concise get those key points
and then you could have a longer version
with more detail that you know
you because you want all that content
maybe you want to pull some things in
and out for different
different job applications
i recommend not trying to have six
different versions of your resume
if you could have one strong version
that then maybe you slightly tweak for
different applications
that's okay um people that try to
completely
reinvent their resume and have four
different resumes for
it it ends up being really inefficient
and it's hard to
get again that momentum and get progress
going and getting a lot of applications
i will turn off the recording now so
we will keep asking questions that way
if you want to mute an essay question
you can
for those of you watching this recorded
thanks for joining
we'll stop